good morning boris johnson is due to
meet his chief scientific advisors today
as he decides whether to bring in new
covert restrictions for england he'll be
given the latest covert data and the
experts advice on what should happen
next to control the omicron outbreak
encouraging figures could mean a lighter
touch worse than expected figures could
mean new tighter controls well the three
other countries of the united kingdom
have now introduced tougher restrictions
from today in scotland venues serving
alcohol will only be allowed to operate
table service and groups of people
meeting will be limited to three
households numbers are capped for
outdoor and indoor events
in northern ireland table service is now
required for all hospitality settings
with a rule of six also in place
indoor standing events are no longer
permitted and socializing is reduced to
a max of three households
in wales the rule of six is in place for
pubs cinemas and restaurants but
nightclubs have closed and only 50
people are allowed at outdoor events
as yet no new restrictions have been
announced for england here's sky's sadia
chaudhry crunch time for the prime
minister who must decide this week
whether plan b measures need to change
whichever path he chooses it's clear
boris johnson won't please everyone
would you like to see further
restrictions come in now yes absolutely
i think the numbers are way too high
we're starting to confuse testing with
uh severity of a disease
um and i wish they'd stopped testing
people
because if we just got on with life we'd
soon be back to normal
but it's the tests which are providing
one of the key indicators hitting over a
hundred thousand positive results for
three days in a row leading up to
christmas
figures weren't released over the
holiday weekend but are expected to
reach new highs when they're outlined
later today
scientists warned the time for action is
now
we're in a little bit of a black hole at
the moment because we don't know what's
happened over the last two days an
argument for restrictions would be to be
able to flatten this curve of cases a
little bit to enable
the hospitals and the nhs and the
services
to be maintained
soaring cases enough to scare the
scottish government into toughening up
restrictions there
no white christmas this year
this and other theater shows now closed
for weeks
in northern ireland there are further
restrictions on hospitality from today
as well as renewed social distancing
rules
testing times in wales too
a return to social distancing and
one-way systems among new measures there
and nightclubs are closed
in england this was the scene last night
open and desperate to stay so
the covid passport situation which we
saw in wales scotland and northern
ireland initially being
administered
that was led to be it was supposed to be
a mitigation that would allow nightclubs
to remain open that clearly hasn't
happened
today boris johnson is expected to
examine the latest hospital data before
making a decision encouraging signs
there and england could be saved from
toughened new rules
but if the figures suggest concern for
the nhs the prime minister may find
himself caught between scientific advice
and back bench reluctance to support new
measures
sadia chowdhury sky news
well there is a fresh call for people
eligible to receive their coronavirus
vaccine to get the jab before the start
of the new year the nhs says there are
more than one and a half million slots
still available that's between now and
the third of january more than 32
million people have now received a
booster dose and a record
1.06 million vaccines were administered
just on wednesday
police have confirmed they're
investigating a video of a man saying he
was going to assassinate the queen as
part of their inquiries into the
security breach at windsor castle on
christmas morning the video was posted
on social media minutes before a 19 year
old man was arrested in the grounds of
the castle armed with a crossbow he has
been detained under the mental health
act let's speak to our correspondent
shaman freeman powell who's in the
newsroom so sherman what do we know
yeah well we know that the man had
obviously managed to enter the grounds
of windsor castle now this has taken
place when the queen was in residence so
this is a huge security concern for the
police however it is worth noting that
the man
didn't manage to enter any of the
buildings the security processes were
triggered moments after the man entered
the grounds and it has been detained
under the mental health act but as i say
this is still a huge concern for the
police the fact that a man was able to
get onto the grounds of windsor castle
armed with a crossbow whilst the queen
was in residence and obviously we've
been widely reported leading up to
christmas that the queen had decided to
stay at windsor castle with her family
during the christmas period now it
hasn't been confirmed yet whether the
man in the video was the same man that
was arrested at windsor castle but the
police have said that the man was
arrested on the grounds of windsor
castle and that detectives are now
looking at that video footage and the
police have also confirmed that it has
been detained under the mental health
act
okay sherman thank you
wildlife and the environment is
suffering the impact of extreme weather
in the uk as the climate gradually
changes birds butterflies and trees are
struggling in some parts of the country
with diseases like ash dieback taking
hold in wetter conditions and wiping out
thousands of trees aisha's head reports
[Music]
changing weather patterns are putting
some of the most idyllic parts of the
country at risk although for many places
it's already too late
earlier this year wildfires devastated
both the mourned mountains in northern
ireland and yorkshire's marsden moor
the jurassic coast saw its largest cliff
fall in 60 years
and storm arwin caused extensive damage
to dozens of rare trees
the new climate normal means the threat
to wildlife continues to grow
while the weather might not always be
eventful it's unseasonal conditions like
drier springs and warmer and wetter
winters that contribute to extreme
weather events putting places like this
at risk and while some species lose out
other parts of our wildlife thrive
it's a build up of all these small
changes that can have the largest
impacts because the climate is changing
and we're seeing different weather
patterns uh that those are out of sync
with the natural
biology and chronology of much of our
wildlife this year we saw
uh butterflies take quite a significant
hit we think that's because
there was a cool spring but critically
it was followed by a very wet bed so you
have this kind of cascade through the
food web through the ecosystems which is
a real challenge and it's impacting on
our wildlife experts say conservation
work will be key in helping restore
nature but to have the desired effect
the next steps will have to be
courageous and bold aisha zahid sky news
parts of canada are experiencing record
low temperatures leading to freezing
rain and extreme cold conditions
environment canada says temperatures
reached as low as minus 50 degrees
celsius in the northwest leading to
weather warnings for canadians
celebrating the holiday and near empty
streets and city centres
so
what does -50
feel like
or look like here's a demonstration
one householder offered to show us
that's a pan of water that immediately
turned to snow isn't that amazing that's
cold
i will not be going out in that
right in other news this morning now the
chief constable of west mercier police
has formally apologized to the family of
the ex-footballer dalian atkinson over
his death atkinson who played for aston
villa sheffield wednesday and ipswich
town died after pc benjamin monk used
excessive force in kicking the 48 year
old in the head and also used a taser on
him in august of 2016.
monk was convicted of manslaughter and
jailed for eight years in june
the family of archbishop desmond tutu
have confirmed his funeral will take
place at st george's cathedral in cape
town on saturday on wednesday there will
be a memorial service and his body will
lie in state on friday tributes have
poured in for the archbishop from all
over the world last night prince charles
wrote of his bravery and speaking out
against the evil of apartheid and said
he was an inspiration for us all
hundreds of u.s flights have been
grounded for a third day amid a surge in
covid19 cases among airline staff the
flight tracking website flightaware
found more than 700 commercial flights
in and out of the states were cancelled
affecting tens of thousands of
passengers over the christmas weekend
about eight thousand flights were
cancelled globally between christmas eve
and boxing day
the business secretary quasi quattang is
expected to meet energy industry leaders
and the regulator off gem today to
tackle the issue of rising energy costs
the government says it will protect
customers through the energy price cap
but it's thought bosses are likely to
ask for tax cuts and the relaxation of
green levees because of the number of
bankruptcies in the sector
a group of swimmers in oxford had to
cancel their boxing day dip after thames
water informed residents of a sewage
release on christmas day the company
warned that untreated sewage was being
released into the river at whitney and
oxfordshire and at west london after
heavy rain adding that it could take up
to four days for the sewage to clear
retail experts say fear of the omicron
variant has led to a big fall in the
number of people out shopping for the
boxing day sales
industry analyst springboard says
figures were down 45 on 2019 but the
british retail consortium says there is
expected to be a boost for online trade
now the pandemic has brought millions of
unpaid carers to the point of financial
desperation
many more people are now dependent on
family and friends helping them with
their care is almost nine out of ten of
those carers claim that their needs have
been ignored by successive governments
some say they are insolvent simply
living day to day katie barnfield
reports
who's this
sarah devotes her life to her daughter
sapphire
with autism and mental health conditions
she can't go to a mainstream school and
needs round-the-clock care but it means
sarah can't work and financially every
day is a struggle
when i lost that extra 80 pound
universal credit a month that was even a
shock
let alone having to find money for my
gas bill my electricity bill which is
increasing daily how worried are you i
suppose day to day um about your
finances
i'm insolvent
i have no credit i don't even have a
proper bank account i have no way of
securing
the next 12 months as they are
sarah is one of millions of unpaid
carers who are living in poverty
kerastros estimates there are now nearly
14 million unpaid carers in the uk
including an extra 5 million who have
become carers since the start of the
pandemic
while there are some state benefits
available to help they can only claim a
carers allowance if they earn less than
128 pounds a week
in a survey exclusively released to sky
news 86 of unpaid carers said they felt
their needs have been ignored by
successive governments
james is 17 and juggles college with
caring for his disabled mum every day
if i have a bad day like and i can't get
out of bed
he has to help me get up and he helps me
get on to
into my chair
like he helps me get dressed
she relies on benefits and because james
is in full-time education his
application for carers allowance was
rejected
it's like it was all as if they were
giving me the choice i would stay at
home care for my mum
or actually get an education
that's not a choice i don't that's not a
choice i want to make i'm not just
speaking for myself this is young carers
i know they do need the money they do
need it to help them survive
it is so
we need
charities say the pressure on unpaid
carers is getting worse as they pick up
where other services are struggling to
cope
alongside more funding for social care
they're pushing the government to
increase carers allowance and make it
more widely available
we know that because of the pandemic and
because of
cuts in services or not being able to
get social care staff for example
some carers have told us that they're
caring for
up to 40 hours a week more than they
have been before which is which is an
incredible amount extra
work that carers have been doing
the government told sky news they
recognised the value of unpaid carers
and have raised the level of carers
allowance since 2010. it is tiring it is
a worry and i think they do need to
realize
that some families really are struggling
but many say without more support they
don't know how they'll survive
katie barnfield sky news
well let's have a look at the front
pages of this morning's papers now and
the times main story claims weddings and
funerals will be exempt from any further
covert restrictions with much of its
front page given over to a smiling photo
of archbishop desmond tutu
an image of the archbishop also
dominates the front page of the guardian
which says the world has lost a champion
of human rights the paper leaves with a
poll suggesting there's widespread
public concern over the state of the nhs
the daily telegraph reports schools are
planning to send whole year groups home
after growing concerns omicron
infections will lead to staff shortages
new year's eve on a knife edge that's
the headline for the daily mirror
the daily mail has more details about
the man who was arrested after breaking
into the grounds of windsor castle on
christmas day
the prime minister is set to give new
year's eve parties a cautious green
light that's according to the daily
express with advice to observe covert
safeguards
and the daily star splashes on how
teenagers are apparently
unable to wash dishes because of
takeaways and dishwashers
now russia is well known for producing
some of the finest ballet dancers in the
world so what does it take for a young
british dancer to become a principal
dancer at one of the great russian
ballet companies well xander parish is
the first british dancer to be employed
by the morinsky ballet in saint
petersburg he's a yorkshire lad he's
from hull and he's been honoured by the
queen for furthering anglo-russian
relations here's our moscow
correspondent dianna magni
[Music]
zander parish has been the principal
dancer at the marienski and some
petersburg since 2017. a yorkshireman
from hull in the top role at one of
russia's most famous ballet companies
my plan was to come here for a year
try and learn some russian style get
some experience try some solos maybe see
how far i could come just by being in
the center of classical russian ballet
which is what this place is basically
the moriniski theatre is the
mecca of classical ballet
parish has been dancing since he was
eight years old he trained with the
royal ballet school and then spent four
years at covent garden but felt that he
wasn't getting the break there he wanted
i was consigned to the spear holding
rolls walking on holding various coats
or trays or cups so i got very
frustrated
and out of the blue
my fairy godfather i have to say
appeared
a valley master from russia came to
common garden and taught class one day
[Music]
i saw in the class
a beautiful young man who's just
probably first second season in the
company and he's so pay attention for my
correction
and he's working so hard
but
he was so weak
very weak like a dancer able to be like
my tutor in act one oh wonderful not
anymore not after 12 years with the
marianski and a total immersion into
russian life and culture it must have
been very challenging though you came
here you didn't know anything about
russia you didn't know anything about
the history you didn't know anything
about the people you didn't know the
language that's correct it was very hard
i must say it was
it was a leap of faith
he's relaxed backstage a confidence
which comes from having mastered your
art but it's also his style friendly
helpful and extremely self-effacing
so does a little bit of nerves help
before a performance there's certainly a
natural adrenaline that kicks in when
the show is getting about to begin
and you've worked hard for performance
you've prepared it's all we can do then
it's just that moment of waiting for the
curtain to go out
[Music]
and this is literally minutes before it
does
the marianski's director of ballet yuri
futiev who brought paris over from
london stays on stage right till the end
the little swans practicing their famous
dance in trainers and christmas socks
as the audience take their seats on the
other side
[Music]
the male dancer's primary role is to
make the bathroom look good and make it
comfortable so if i can achieve my goal
to make her comfy and keep her on her
leg keep her happy then you know you're
halfway home it's going to be a good
show
i've sacrificed a lot to be where i am
i didn't have a social life for
20 years whatever like i've literally
worked my my socks off to to get to
where i am and i
i don't claim to be the best dancer
around there are many other dancers who
are much more talented than i am i was
quite what's the word i was very
tenacious i wouldn't give up and i
really wanted to succeed
a british prince in a very russian fairy
tale parish has also been awarded an obe
for furthering relations between the uk
and russia
a symbol of friendship between people at
a tense time between their governments
dyna magnay sky news st petersburg
one of our top stories and that breaking
news yesterday morning was that um
desmond tutu
had died he died peacefully in his sleep
aged 90 in cape town he was an
uncompromising foe of apartheid and a
modern-day activist for racial justice
and lgbt rights and last night the south
african president cyril ramaphosa
addressed his nation calling desmond tu
to an icon of peace and freedom here's
our africa correspondent john sparks
his body had been weakened by sickness
but his spirit was strong and his moral
standing unshakable
and south africans praised his name at a
service of thanksgiving in october
this held on his 90th birthday for
desmond tutu was a titan of the
anti-apartheid movement a priest and a
prophet an uncomfortable opponent to all
those in power we are the rainbow people
of god
one man inspires us all i ask you
welcome
our brand new state president
out of the fox
nelson mandela
they stood hand in hand on the day
nelson mandela became the country's
first democratically elected president
a fitting site inspired and propelled by
the oratory of this anglican cleric
this is the day for which we have waited
for over 300 years
[Applause]
this is the day
of liberation
desmond tutu was ordained a few months
after sharpville
the site of a massacre in 1960 where 69
black south africans were killed
it was a turning point for the country
and the man and he used his position in
the church as a platform to advocate for
the oppressed
tutu was awarded the nobel peace prize
in 1984 and used the publicity to
increase the pressure for change
and when ten years later he got the
chance to vote well he couldn't contain
his joy
when the newly elected government
decided to investigate the crimes of the
apartheid era desmond tutu was the
obvious choice to lead its truth and
reconciliation commission
but it wasn't easy and the archbishop
very publicly broke down
midway through the process he was
diagnosed with prostate cancer but it
didn't slow him down his democratic
rights used to castigate the ruling anc
for corruption mismanagement and
ignoring the plight of the poor i want
vote for them
that is something that i have said
and i say it with a very sore very heavy
heart
we dreamed about a society that would be
compassionate
a society that really made people
feel they mattered
in his later years public appearances
became more infrequent
but he retained his sense of humor and
his sense of moral purpose his faith no
barrier to the compassion he felt for
the oppressed worldwide
he was frank
and forthright
speaking truth to power
even when this meant criticizing the
democratic government
it was through both his words and his
actions
that he earned his distinguished place
in the history of our nation's struggle
for freedom i don't think one can
be involved in conflict mediation
um or in dealing with wars and civil
wars and disruption and disconnection
around the world without always asking
oneself
what would desmond have done we
as the family
really make peace with the fact that we
should let him go
we cannot expect
a man who's given so much of his life
to be there forever he was asked how he
would like to be remembered and the
priest who helped shape a nation
responded with this
he loved
he laughed
he cried
he was forgiven
he forgave
desmond tutu will be remembered around
the world with love and gratitude for he
has left it a better place on his
passing
john sparks sky news in johannesburg
now the tokyo olympics saw many
successes for team gb the performance of
the bmx team was one of the most
dominant and certainly one of the most
watchable at the end of the most
successful year bmx has ever known sky's
tom palmento sat down with tokyo silver
medalist kai white to reflect and look
at what's coming next
you are riding with an olympian
kai white's bmx does some incredible
things
and this year it inspired so many others
to just have a go
off the back of the best olympics this
sport has ever seen
freestyle made its debut gold for
charlotte worthington bronze for declan
brooks
when kai white raced to silva he was
crowned the prince of peckham he then
watched bethany shriva take gold moments
later and then scooped her off the track
was that the best moment of your life
that day
best and worst yeah best and worse
obviously i i was running the race and
then i made mistakes
and then i got second
that was the worst part
and then the best part was obviously
accepting it accepting that still got a
medal out of like zero zero zero point
one percent in the in the world i'm just
a kid from perk i'm really like this
time i still see myself as a kid from
peckham so
yeah it's been quite crazy i feel like
we still need to prove ourselves um even
now even after yeah yeah yeah
because i feel like
villager may have had the countless
medals uh we just we're just getting
started now
so what would you say to people who have
seen you and bethany and the freestylers
doing your thing on a bike and thought
yeah maybe
do not get just get up and do it that's
the only thing i can say release get up
and do it how you guys finding are you
good yeah
did you like it even with the problems
caused by the pandemic participation at
some bmx clubs is up 200
over the past two years have you noticed
that more kids from peckham and all over
the country want to ride a bmx now a
hundred percent i had so many messages i
still can go through them now
where
i've had good and bad actually that the
good ones are oh you've helped my kid
get back on the bike my kids started
being met because of you one of the bad
messages was
i'm proud that you made my kid get back
on but he went to the skate park or i
went to bed track and he crashed broke
his teeth i was like
i mean this part of the sport
yeah i'm sorry to hear that
he's even trying his hand at ice skating
on the telly soon but the only prize kai
white really wants is an upgrade to that
medal when he rides in paris in 2024
it will be for gold
tom parmenter sky news manchester